noi di solito il più delle volte non
siamo svegli noi non siamo presenti e
questo vuol dire che non siamo nella
consapevolezza per aumentare la
consapevolezza bisogna praticare la
presenza la meditazione attraverso la
presenza della meditazione
noi stiamo nell'auto consapevolezza
l'autoconsapevolezza vuol dire dimorare
nell'essenza di noi stessi nel profondo
di noi stessi e da lì possiamo operare
questo dimorare nell'essenza di noi
stessi non è così lontano dalla parola
economia economia è formata da due
parole oikos e nomi a abitare nomos
nella legge nella verità nel d'arma e
quindi non vuol dire semplicemente
occupare uno spazio fisico ma vuol dire
appunto cercare di essere in sintonia
con se stessi con gli altri e con tutto
l'ambiente e da questo da questo
dimorare se stessi e quindi questa
pratica questo modo di fare la vera
sfida è di cercare di portarlo fuori di
portarlo nel nostro fare nell'azione
nella quotidianità e ancor più la sfida
e portarla nel lavoro e quindi questa è
stata la mia sfida
e così ho cercato di costruire l'azienda
di cercare di costruire di portare
l'economia un paradigma nuovo paradigma
che usciva da questa dicotomia da questa
dualità che la nostra mente sempre ci fa
vivere che le aziende buone sono quelle
che non fanno utile le aziende cattive
sono quelle che sono business to
business solamente utili utili e ho
detto no bisogna fare una sintesi più
alta e più evolutiva di questi due
aspetti ma come macola il ritorno deve
essere fatto di un'azienda in un
ristorante in un bar
piccolo grande che sia perché se io ho
un ritorno finanziario posso investire
risorse possa investire in ricerca e
sviluppo
posso pagare gli stipendi fornitori e
poi soprattutto ciò degli utili e posso
devolvere una parte degli utili pagando
le tasse alla comunità allora io devo
fare un economia nel rispetto delle
persone e nel rispetto dell'ambiente
così io posso perseguire anche un
ritorno finanziario
così ho costruito e come l'ho costruita
come ho cercato di portare in pratica
tutto questo ho cercato di portare in
pratica prima cosa scrivendo un codice
etico
oggi se ne sente molto parlare io vi
parlo che siamo alla fine del 90 come
cosa codice etico dove appunto le
persone dovevano essere trattate devono
essere trattate come dei fini e come non
come dei mezzi per raggiungere delle
scopi dove non ci devono essere
disuguaglianze religiose politiche
razziali di questo genere qui dove i
nostri fornitori noi lavoriamo con
fornitori che vengano da quattro
continenti perché abbiamo erbe radici
che vengano da quattro continenti e
quindi questi fornitori volta oltre a
darci una qualità alta ci devono dare
una una carta su cui loro si devono
impegnare che devono rispettare
l'ambiente e devono rispettare le
persone che lavorano per loro stessi poi
ho messo all'interno della società anche
un bilancio ambientale un codice di
sicurezza sul lavoro un codice di
sicurezza alimentare e quindi ho cercato
di costruire in pratica su quello che
appunto sentivo dicevo che mi è stato
trasmesso e poi in azienda e l'azienda
come organizzare un azienda la prima
cosa è cercare di passare da una logica
di potere a una logica di responsabilità
quando uno va in un'azienda arriva un
direttore si deve leggere un
amministratore delegato qualche cosa di
questo genere tutti di che poteri di
daino la parola comune e potere io
invece ho passato la parola
responsabilità quando a me vengano da me
mi chiedo ma che poteri mida io gli dico
a voi non vi do nessun potere
li vedo queste persone che stramazzano
al suolo la poteri ma allora cosa mi
prende dicono io vi do delle
responsabilità responsabilità
responsabilità abile a rispondere è
qualche cosa che è veramente vicino alla
consapevolezza e quindi questa cosa qui
poi cercato di inserire la meritocrazia
però collaborativa cosa vuol dire che se
uno ha un idea gli altri devono
collaborare insieme a bree questa perché
questa idea abbia successo e quindi
viene pregante premiata tutta la squadra
poi ho cercato di portare avanti un
discorso di comunicazione quindi uscire
da un'azienda legata a silos ma cercare
di portare quello che appunto una
comunicazione tutti devono sapere quello
che l'azienda vuole raggiungere quello
che deve fare tutti devono cooperare
insieme per quell'obiettivo e quindi
essere proattivi proattivi cosa vuol
dire vuol dire sapere il porto perché se
uno nella vita non sa il porto dove
andare
non ci potrà essere mai vento favorevole
che ti faccia arrivare a quel porto poi
l'ho cercata di mettere in maniera
semplice
il che vuol dire in maniera non troppo
semplice semplice vuol dire appunto in
maniera che sia efficace e efficiente ma
la grande sfida dove l'ho avuta l'ha
avuta in argentina l'argentina ed alla
fine degli anni 90
vado in argentina e li ho veramente
messo in pratica tutto quello che mi era
stato trasmesso e li ho incominciato a
viagra vagare per l'argentina per buon
esare sarà una situazione economica
molto difficile e allora mettevo in
pratica il vedere il vedere quindi la
chiara visione a chiara visione vuol
dire vedere la realtà per quella che è e
poi l'ascoltare quante volte noi non
ascoltiamo gli altri
noi ascoltiamo gli altri attraverso la
nostra immagine che abbiamo dell'altro
ascoltiamo l'altro attraverso i
condizionamenti conformismi
noi diamo dei giudizi invece ascoltare
pure i liberi da tutto questo
andavo in giro e stavo capendo che
nell'argentina succedeva qualche cosa di
veramente grosso importante
e allora dico io devo spostare tutti i
soldi all'estero e li apriti cielo tutti
mica ma no non è possibile
i soldi devono stare qui spostare i
soldi all'estero nell'errore magistrale
però dentro di me sentivo con tutto me
stesso questa cosa qui e allora quando
se uno sente con tutto se stesso non c'è
bisogno di scegliere deve fare quello
che sente realmente così l'ho fatto ho
mandato tutti i soldi all'estero e dopo
due mesi
l'argentina è andata in default cosa
vuol dire vuol dire che appunto est
fallita uno stato che fallisce quei
soldi se fossero rimasti lì sarebbero
diventati la metà della metà della metà
poi con l'inflazione galoppante la metà
della metà
quindi non avremmo avuto quasi più
nessun soldo quei soldi li mi sono
serviti moltissimo per poter andare
avanti per poter pagare gli stipendi
per poter contare le materie prime per
fare tutte queste cose qui e lì ho messo
in pratica un'altra cosa che mi era
stata insegnata che è quello di non
lamentarsi quello di non lamentarsi
quando c'è un problema e siccome la vita
è fatta di problemi ci sono il challenge
le sfide e ci sono e c'è la felicità
questa è la vita e quindi il più delle
volte noi stiamo nel lamentarsi quando
siamo nel lamentarsi cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che non siamo nella presenza e
quindi lo stando nella presenza non
vedendo il problema non abbiamo la
possibilità di creare quello spazio per
trovare la risoluzione del problema
così ho riunito attorno a me tutte le
persone che lavorano con me e gli ho
detto sei ore questa è la situazione
la vita ci dà a tutti una grandissima
opportunità di mettere il meglio di noi
stessi in pratica e quindi vediamo cosa
si può fare
noi abbiamo di fronte a noi gli ho detto
3 azione una azione è quella aggressiva
la sanno fare tutti chiudiamo come tante
aziende hanno chiuso qui in argentina
una cosa semplice non c'è bisogno di
mettere il meglio di noi
una seconda azione e quella conservativa
quella che fa il buon padre di famiglia
quanti soldi mi entrano e tanti soldi
io cerco di organizzare la famiglia per
dare e poi ci abbiamo un attestazione
che è quella creativa ecco signori noi
abbiamo questa opportunità di mettere
questo sono passati mesi prima di
trovare la soluzione
poi alla fine è venuta l'insight la
creatività l'abbiamo messa in pratica
abbiamo inventato un prodotto di pronta
beva come se fosse un vino novello
quindi non era il prodotto principale
invecchiato in anno un anno in botti di
rovere con le spezie le radici che venga
un amaro di pronta aveva facile buono
onesto ed è pronta beva
e così in questi due anni noi abbiamo
traghettato la società fuori da quello
che era il default dal fallimento
e questo è stato un grandissimo successo
per tutti ma soprattutto è stato un
successo perché in questi due anni in
argentina
tutto andava male è una grande
quotidiana argentino ha detto tutto va
male meno male che c'è freni e perché
eravamo rimasti tra le poche aziende
rimaste
il logo è la cosa più bella che a me mi
ha dato veramente grande soddisfazione è
stato il fatto che noi eravamo 120
persone dirette a lavorare in azienda
più 110 che eravamo indiretti così siamo
partiti e alla fine del default
eravamo 120 130 230 quindi neanche una
persona in un momento di fallimento
dello stato si è dovuta mandare a casa e
questa è stata la più grande gioia
grazie
io cosa ho capito da tutto questo ho
capito che veramente una cosa importante
per tutti noi è trovare l'equilibrio le
nell'equilibrio c'è la verità e quindi
trovare questo giusto equilibrio tra
l'intelligenza tra il cuore e tra il
coraggio perché l'intelligenza col
coraggio il cuore col coraggio da soli
non possono altro che creare del male e
l'intelligenza col cuore da soli e poi
non trovano la forza per poter attuare
quello che ha uno ha in mente quindi
quello che è importante e quando una ed
una un'idea prima di agire depositata
nel cuore e pensare dire ma questa idea
che io ho è un qualche cosa che fa bene
solo per me o può far bene anche per gli
altri
allora quando uno vede che qualche cosa
che può far bene anche per gli altri
mettere in pista il coraggio e in questa
maniera veramente possiamo far sì che
diventi pratica e possiamo creare un
umanesimo integrato
oggi si sente parlare tanto di crisi
crisi crisi per me è più il piace più la
parola opportunità
comunque visto che tutti la chiamano
crisi diciamo che la crisi appunto
oggigiorno che viviamo è una crisi
politica è una crisi economica è una
crisi ecologica è una crisi di valore
quindi è una crisi che all'interno di
noi perché quello che c'è fuori non è
altro che l'esterna lizzazione di quello
che hai dentro di noi quando noi capiamo
che il mondo fuori lo costruiamo noi è
qualcosa di veramente fondamentale e
quindi non è una crisi di passaggio come
sono stati nel passato questa è una
crisi vera reale una crisi di
cambiamento che cosa ci dice questa
crisi questo momento questa opportunità
che noi c'abbiamo di capire la coscienza
che ci ha portato a questi livelli la
coscienza che ci fa agire in questa
maniera e cercare di fare un salto
quantico un salto quantico vuol dire
della coscienza di andare al di là dello
spazio del tempo per passare da un io
egoico
a 1 e per sentirsi io umanità grazie